The Copanhaguen summit left many things
unresolved.
But we need to move on and advance.
Colombia has proposed that the preservations
of the jungles is fundamental
in any policy against climate change. And
that, the conservation of the jungle must
be remunerated.
Colombia, as an example, we've been working
on a program of "Forester Family",
families in charge of the destruction of the
forests, in the case of Colombia, by growing
cocaine.
We have come to an agreement with those families
so that they keep the forests cocaine-free,
and they get remunerated.
We believe that in the world, Global Warming
policy must be committed to the principle
of the conservation of the jungle
and in the principle of remuneration for the
conservation of the jungle.